[Musique]
bonjour bertrand oui bonjour 10 me
bonjour à tout le monde bonjour garrel
grataloup bonjour a vous d vous êtes
responsable de communication de
madininair l'association madininair qui
se préoccupent on va dire de la qualité
de l'air en martinique vous êtes
responsable de communication de
madininair depuis 13 ans maintenant
comme le temps a passé c'est vrai c'est
remercier
alors ce matin vous êtes venu nous
parler d'une expérimentation inédite qui
a cours en martinique avec des micro
capteurs citoyens de quoi s'agit-il et
comment se présente ses capteurs comment
ça marche quoi alors en effet c'est une
expérience
expérimentation vraiment innovante donc
il repose sur des des nouvelles
technologies donc ce sont des micro
capteurs qui tiennent vraiment dans la
boîte qui tient dans la main qu'ils vont
mesurer donc tout on a fait le choix de
mesurer les particules fines puisque
c'est une problématique importante en
martinique donc trois types de
particules fines celles qui sont
inférieures à 10 micromètres donc c'est
qu'on mesure généralement avec nos
moyens de façon accrédités en fait à
made in her les particules inférieures à
2,5 et les plus petites particules
inférieures à 1 micromètre de corps
alors on va oui donc ce boîtier en fait
il est à péret avec une une application
et se permet de visualiser les données
en temps réel c'est vraiment des mesures
en temps réel lorsque lorsqu'on lance
l'application d'accords donc ça
fonctionne avec le téléphone tout à fait
téléphone portable
avant de préciser qu'elle particules
fines exactement vous voulez mesurer
il faut préciser qu'elle est menée en
partenariat avec la rs cette action qui
est qui est prévu par le troisième plan
régional santé environnement le perez e
3 en effet c'est une action qui
s'inscrit dans le prs e3 donc qui est
piloté par l' agence régionale de santé
et là des halles donc financé par l'
agence régionale de santé la volonté de
cette action c'était il ya deux choses
c'était vraiment une approche
donc psycho sociologique c'est à dire
rendre visible l'invisible parce que
parfois la qualité de l'air on s'en rend
pas compte on voit pas comment on expose
y est c est donc c'était utiliser des
nouveaux moyens des moyens inédits donc
les micro capteurs qui sont vraiment
tout nouveau sur sur le marché au niveau
national notamment et bien sûr locales
et donc voir si ce type de mesures bien
sûr qu'ils n'ont pas la même qualité de
mesures que nous à paris des deux
mesures mais qui ont la proche
individuel permet justement de mieux
percevoir la qualité de l'air permet de
changer éventuellement quelques
habitudes par rapport à la qualité de
l'air est le deuxième intérêt pour nous
aussi c'est justement d'évaluer ces
dispositifs est ce qu ils peuvent être
un moyen complémentaire à nos
observations sur la qualité de l'air ils
paient ce qu'ils peuvent enrichir notre
système de surveillance voilà s'il ya
vraiment deux approches dans cette danse
est exact dans cette action cette
dimension citoyenne et et psychologique
auprès des individus est importante
parce que des connaissances
scientifiques sur les particules en
suspension en martinique en particulier
les particules fines vous en avez déjà
madininair pour preuve vous vous publiez
un état des lieux des connaissances
scientifiques actuelles sur ces
particules en suspension donc c'est pour
aller un peu plus loin au delà de 2 je
dirais de l'enregistrement et de la
connaissance un peu technique de enfin
pas un peu beaucoup de technique de oui
c'est vraiment en effet depuis plus de
20 ans made in her mesure la qualité de
l'air et notamment les particules fines
donc on a vraiment acquis un certain
nombre de données donc en effet le
rapport dont vous faisait allusion c'est
vraiment un recueil justement de tout ce
qu'on peut savoir sur les particules
fines en martinique et dans la caraïbe
puisqu'il ya une partie revue
bibliographique recherche scientifique
puis vraiment une analyse statistique
qualitative que quantitative de nos
données sur plein de types de particules
donc en effet on a beaucoup donné donc
là est en effet comme vous le signalez
c'est vraiment une autre approche dans
cette mesure c'est plus est ce que ça
peut être un levier d'action
pour changer son comportement pour mieux
percevoir la qualité de l'air est ce que
ça peut aider certaines type de
population à se rendre compte de son
exposition à la pollution de l'air
alors cela est passé par le recrutement
de 40 volontaires
comment vous vous y êtes pris com
comment avez-vous procédé il y avait-il
des critères spéciaux alors c'est cette
action cette mobilisation citoyenne donc
elle est financée par l'argent serait
chouette santé où l'avait dit et puis
elle est réalisée en partenariat avec
une association de recherche qui
s'appelle arrêt bio est donc dans cette
association s'est associé à des deux
psychologues sociaux sociaux et
environnementaux
donc l'idée c'était en effet d'avoir un
échantillon donc 40 pour une étude pour
une étude de recherche c'est un petit
échantillon mais on a souhaité vraiment
les accompagner au mieux dans cette
expérimentation
on a souhaité donc cibler les des
habitants de communes dites sensibles à
la qualité de l'air faut savoir que
depuis quelques années on il ya des
communes qui sont classés sensibles à la
qualité de l'air donc c'est le cas de
saint pierre de belle fontaine
fort-de-france lamentin schoelcher ducos
rivière salée robert
jarry n'oubliez est donc ce sont ces
communes sont concernées donc là déjà
exactement les personnes qui ont été
sélectionnés sont déjà issus de six de
ces communes ensuite on a essayé d'avoir
un échantillon assez représentatif en
termes d'âge de catégorie
socioprofessionnelle en terme de deux
hommes femmes parité etc même si il faut
l'avouer les femmes sont souvent plus
intéressés par les questions
environnementales
et puis et du coup avec voilà
différentes approches et on a pu avoir
un recueillir donc on a eu plus de 200
paires de souhaits de participation à
cette expérimentation et puis après il
ya eu un premier questionnaire aussi
derrière de dévaluation des perceptions
et des attitudes vis-à-vis de la qualité
de l'air qui nous a permis aussi de de
réduire un petit peu pour choisir les 40
personnes donc vous êtes arrêté à 40,1
finalement créé que ça voilà c'est
vraiment l'idée c'est vraiment d'avoir
une première une première
expérimentation or on voit et quand
présent de projets et puis avec d'autres
partenaires des collectivités notamment
des professionnels de santé qui a un
souhait de poursuivre notamment par
rapport à des critères de santé
peut-être poids avec plus de personnes
qui sont qui souffrent d'asthme
d'allergies etc mais là c'était une
volonté d'avoir un
quelqu'un échantillons un premier
échantillon et voir comment ça se passe
avec ces micro capteurs donc elle
pourrait être amenée à être renouvelé
par les actuels mans cette opération
alors on l'a compris c'est une démarche
citoyenne participative donc mais vous
dites aussi pédagogique en quoi laisse
pédagogique et ben le permet justement
de se rendre contre de 7,7 cette
exposition avec des démesures ensuite
dans un donc là pour l'instant donc on a
lancé vraiment là depuis
on a recours depuis de vivre voilà
depuis quelques semaines de quelques
jours en effet nos mots nos volontaires
donc mesure donc on est en lien avec eux
déjà on voit que certains retours
notamment par rapport à l'épisode de
pollution qui a connu ces derniers temps
donc voilà on voit vraiment déjà qu' une
prise de conscience
de cette exposition des gens tousser est
censé favoriser cette prise de
conscience est là parce que on les
accompagne aussi avec des dandys on leur
propose des activités d des situations
où il peut mesurer parce que nous on si
on
stimule un petit peu là l'expérience est
donc ils peuvent confronter certaines
situations par exemple l'aération de
leur logement lorsqu un pic de pollution
pas de pic de pollution du coup certains
se rendre compte parfois de ces de
certaines attitudes qui sont peut-être
pas qui était peut-être des idées reçues
et qui permettent de faire évoluer les
choses donc déjà le retour qu'on a
simplement après quelques jours il est
déjà très intéressant ils sont des
volontaires vraiment qu'ils sont engagés
et motivés et donc ça c'est c'est très
agréable et puis à terme donc après la
réalité c'est quand même de les laisser
un petit peu faire leur propre
expérience et puis après c'est monsieur
mois de mesure que ça va durer un mois
de mesures libre avec des temps en temps
des expériences spécifiques on va faire
des ateliers pour aller un peu plus loin
pour leur apporter des connaissances
supplémentaires parce que forcément ils
vont ils soulèvent on voit déjà qu'ils
posent des questions pu pousser et donc
l'idée c'est d'enrichir leurs
connaissances pour que puis derrière ils
peuvent être eux mêmes des relais on
voit qu'ils sont ils ont mis entre
guillemets les engage aussi leur
entourage dans cette expérience il en
parle et c'est donc voilà pour nous
c'est important de faire cet effet boule
de neige
se sont que des adultes 1
après ils partagent en effet lé nounours
que les personnes volontaires sont des
adultes mais on voit que dans certains
foyers qu'est le canadair en effet il
est partagée
des enfants les adolescents donc ça se
passe ça se fait tant en extérieur qu'en
intérieur
ce capteur si elle al'avantage d'être
mobile on peut l'utiliser soit en
déplacement la tâche par exemple à sa
ceinture à son sac donc on peut faire en
marchant en faisant son sport faisant du
vélo etc l'utiliser et puis on peut
utiliser comme une station entre
guillemets fixe c'est à dire qu'on le
pose à un endroit par exemple au milieu
de sa pièce de vie à la maison et on
peut mesurer les particules fines en
extérieur idem à quand les premiers
résultats les premières restitution vous
prévost l'esa pour quand alors sur les
premières restitution dans un mois on va
voir quelque chose quelques quelques
résultats on va essayer de les présenter
on n'aura pas le temps de tout tout
traiter les éventuelles voilà au niveau
des rangs de dix rencontres puisque on
rencontre ces volontaires et puis et
puis l'idée c'est surtout en fin d'année
d'avoir ce rapport complet à la fois la
preuve du sycot sociologique et la fois
analyse de données pour pouvoir faire un
bilan de tout savoir quel est l'intérêt
de ce dispositif ce qui a des limites on
leur a demandé vraiment d'être franc est
dans une démarche de co construction
voilà nous même nous on maîtrise pas
certains aspects technologiques
il ya des bugs etc mais il faut qu'on
ait ce retour est ce que mesuré que les
particules fines c'est suffisant voilà
c'est vraiment dans une démarche d'éco
construction merci égalera talent ou
d'avoir répondu à ces questions